tell you that our program is slightly
altered for what appears as a program
unfortunately professor Deborah mushy
does not need to be with us today sony
has three presentations rather than four
and we're going to try to end this
session at four o'clock rather than 415
to allow for a half hour into this next
one I know many people here have come
from far away I flew in from California
this morning and so rest grades are
getting full content so mean three
wonderful presentations in this panel on
gender and generational relations and
the first is Chester see momentum
peterson me from the University of rent
in France and it is entitled under
tension between his lung and France and
his wrong of friends and she was going
to move over chair to the podium aback
unless she has some specialist
presentation and I mean we like moves
between Milton of France and New Zealand
trends I've been growing she'd hate due
to the piety of immigration policies in
frank Lautenberg but also because of the
criminally that are restrained number of
immigrants and political refugees would
favor a better information of the
innocent freshman enemy we became an
indicator of the religious
categorization act differently according
to the gender and regeneration slaves I
with result a present the sunny day
books about transmission and we propose
but uber a proposal met distracting the
logic of revolutionary movement that is
the augmentation for editing from keith
lemon friends to even call friends
firstly the religious immigration
deficiency of categorization of earnest
as an increases of redundant workers in
accidentally that accompanied the
analysis of the religious religiosity of
late millions for example the work of
joining 40 on catalysis map of Jewish
religion liberation started to be
studied in France especially in relation
with is on each moment is a categorical
for political analysis that is already
movement is adopted economics without
any distance between the ages and knives
according to Nancy
Islam become the motive the motives of
her distinguish the new leader the
violence from the former one former
migrants have been here mainly
associated with European and George
polish would have been able to integrate
into the political process while there
are no way nowadays consider to be
mostly Harold Macmillan's and from the
French coalition so there are three
categories this decision is also related
with our image organization of European
migration policies I mean the opposition
between Europeans and non-routine
millions mind the idea of evolution is
incremented what other categories of
music that researcher immigrates on
between the eighties and nineties this
is the question the production of
several categories of novel of movements
and the gradual dissociation from
migration categories in deities modern
workers are the main focus on us these
movements are tolerated because they are
expected to return to that angry old the
883 strides in regard to see are
accompanied by religion slaves in
particular related to work to worship
which will be in a first moment for it
but we later on gradually vinglish
emulation with the Declaration of
working condition of working conditions
degree of unemployment rates the closure
of many factories indeed I noticed there
is action in the focus on isla by
separating more more immigration and
this one and look at ivory emerged in
August I don't need to watch now
considered to be deep with liberal
friends friends young women with migrant
background especially Islamist world
with hard stuff in particular the shift
from those we don't know whether they
will say or not to French men and women
with specifically with specific
religious their assignment proposition
the resistor external to the nation
series be attributed to the cultural
criteria and emphasize religious
preacher cartel as a matter of fact in
the nineties the Magnusson culture
replaces the eighties focus on the
future of origin while under the label
of original culture prayer rooms in the
factories had beaten raped with idea
that migrant workers could only
turn to their country music culture will
be assigned to the freshman and being
with background and they re appropriated
it also treated as a problem of Public
Order primary related French men and
women with backgrounds these it work of
friends people's first effort of origin
of expectation or of suspicion the issue
of Islam in Europe is today a political
beauties the presence of Muslims is
inevitable and without backtracking the
question and the change for all Muslim
and non-muslim no music is world even in
Newark can be can become even from
Europe in connection with cross created
evil then the idea of a rupture with the
phone services of visibility of minutes
workers because many elite mutants go to
move to break but create alternative
spaces around educational and cultural
activities to equate that faith with
their social life as said earlier world
in
this gradual movement of his own friends
who isn't from France means means
recognizing that most of these young
Muslims were burned French and educate
in fact reduce the Android design thomas
paine's reduce politics under categories
of publication and the grammar of
belonging that is understood since its
information as programmatic finally the
gradual concentration of research on the
answers with migrant backgrounds mostly
focus on girls wearing the masks are in
the public service and the public
schools in particular and it's move-in
is mostly low here at its articulation
with regimes of citizenship however the
political regime and legitimacy of the
identification of citizenship as a
problem that must the lead to a
legislative resource is in doing
scientific analysis ah but I have yahoo
road in a 25 each way 200
2005 what is the atom of that the 2004
low which band at the head stuff in
public trollin republic of fat dividend
divided the family's movement in France
new tradition is preferable to the low
and carbon sexism and hamster versus
representative of French majority
families such as assisting the field
within the family's collective for
equality that also includes young music
winner with backgrounds which refer to
Islam as a venue for the claim of
individual rights Moroccan music
families that lambda beta is the founder
of a current president of international
growth group for study and reflection on
women in Islam the z-axis and interest
rate the transnational dimension of this
dynamic these music palace grows
included museum women from Europe North
America North African countries and from
the Middle Earth is it illustrated with
illustrated with the opportunity
provided by identification
with informal learning to develop
transnational dynamic international
congress and symposia organized by
Beasley families like the box alone
after two 2005 congrats you straight to
the legitimacy of sharing experience and
music fans discourses we're beyond the
context of migration the division are
not so much on your food opposition
between my battery contacts and
countries where these amis the majority
the differences it is in the GFE are
related to the consideration of their
saved sacred religious types and the
relation to the school considering the
four national values of Islam that I
have Sophie presented which is an
example that amusing families how can we
still cited today that the more Islam is
becoming friend nationalized and
affiliated to the national context the
more it seems overtaken by valuation it
has been investigated in order contacts
for example for example the work of our
salsa Alex in Messiah illustrated this
constant interaction between the newly
migrants 40 miles and dashes of
immigrants blood work this is involved
because for rent in confidence in
constant terms we know that in France
the ever in
number of music different people mainly
or legal English failure ramification
marriage there are there are more
skilled workers and asylum seekers and
lick you legally directions this could
contain a stable population grid of
beauty over 1600 for miles without visa
originating mailing from Asia and North
and Central Africa part two which are
the music figures that are forgotten in
this shape from New Zealand friends to
musics from friends my answer is that
looking at my mothers and their children
could help us to identify them for what
a reciprocal it is important to
understand Islam about migrant mothers
and their children I have analyzed I the
identification to people and positioning
of social factors in France who did not
seem irrelevant as using actors leader
in fact policy nor huge in French
society with ena ena
violence I've been reduced to certain
realities interesting something like a
cultural tradition basket organza
graphical data tradition we are a bitch
and they they this will seem to be a day
also dangerous per day is like the
daughter furthermore some litter is a
very boundaries especially in the
natural world which is one of the few to
take into account the position of
parental transmission preserve a passive
process of incorporation of emitted by
the children deficient Oh Rose had the
primary person in charge of newborn
babies mothers contributes within a
relationship of body care emotional and
intellectual development of human beings
to unionize and exercise that their
children research that were limited to
the study production and reproduction of
ethnicity from the perspective of room
in position and neglected the active
role children in process in the process
of transition they forgot them into the
children can also be started from the
perspective of unexpected displays
produce the intercourse of interactions
that are not destroyed is really
and the process of transmission
we can ask now how can young children
contributes to modify the parent
orientation while presenting themselves
as new for example this is the middle of
the cry I will follow that I heard from
young boys I brought to cinema during
school ignition and it is also the set
for young girls I staff rope around the
neck and covering the hairline to
pretend to be wearing a staff in early
afternoon during the winter all this an
educator from of ladybug and myself a
company to a dozen stab the students
from prior primary school to see a movie
or lead the Paris Metro a shrewd man
noticed one with contact lenses is also
ready happened before it is in this
prayer insulting someone found it the
teacher then accompanied Suleiman to the
pharmacy and suggested that I ability to
the church which is all tied to the
place we work with the other student
answering the featured suggestions I
have been thinking of involving the
parents for a while we are not very
open-minded there is nothing wrong in
visiting a church you're looking at
interior the same way as we which is
mostly in edit I made the proposal to
the group then the capture which can be
visited as abusive and not view
as a place of worship the answer is
over- our parents do not want us to do
that we are all right go inside a
Christian Church they shot laughs
Elizabeth Rigby these students
considered invitation of entering the
church and a formulation the first
reaction life is involved a normative
reference that their parents make
objective a valid object is also shows
that light in the internals a universal
values in which Christianity places of
worship conceptual poor represent a
cultural difference that made them that
may make them until into city to say in
Ranikhet impossible or enforce a
physical basis that they want to kill
when they announced it just outside the
church relying year on Simone Perkins
while grant educator is treating to
cancel it under the pretext of opening
that runs this general
themselves a technology through their
bodies but also through specific goals
such as clothing or language they are
available in the social space whoever
these tools were not necessarily
intended to be used in that way when
using kids to perform a prism amusing
identities they don't always behave as
children mood for instance plain or not
the Islam in which they eat chicken left
the way their parents educators and
teachers would or who decides this is
what we found in interaction mention
Europe in front of the church in Paris
and in the forum discussion with adults
design books and those that some of them
are likely to receive
you can see colors like pink these are
birds and tourists that some of them are
likely to receive our way of reminding
them what would be the right way to act
I have mutant children and to suggest
that they should do for their group or
below the the museum of science but they
may not use such toys bypassed in the
sexual and religious increase messages
diagnose whether intentional or
unconscious base was more day private
such as the use of invocation dois of
before the time or they are made of
clear parent request for children to
play when they are seven years old this
setting community leader to focus on
your parents reducing children to
passive vesicles or endorse this
neglected of children in with your
immigration situation
the astonishment of models which I
narrated X's the image of the other
judges of the same magnitude as that of
many parents learned that their daughter
in a later age means technically never
them feel that they need something
education and the position will be
serving the freshest eyes many parents
believe that their children regardless
of age are not inside to publicly there
is no mames know that they are
traditions with their daughters on
issues of modesty and acuity when taking
this version does allow link the future
that may produce section triple duty
huge news the young women of North
Africa deli manager monstrous in
relation to specific roles and
generation this modest is built under de
vis they in norman smokers whoever
effects of imputation modesty that
sometimes end up surprising the modules
resolv and are sometimes struck by the
reaction they considered excessive share
of their puters rubber-legged put
themselves with the same days money is
to focus on the oven miss
in the parietal formation of both sides
hugs elements are implicated in the
interaction by this young children in
event of the margins of monitor of the
orig generation situations and
generations indeed trying to fold is
allergic privatization of Islam many
researchers pointed to the lack of
religious games or that is in religious
transition for freshman and French women
with brown backgrounds but it is more
interesting to see how children are
positioned against multiple
configuration of transition in other
cases these settings can write an eager
to focus on your parents reducing
children to pass reciprocals nor indoors
is neglect of childhood migration satish
or to take little if the young women
were there at the scorer's interim who
say that a hard cut at cut maternal
transmission feeling a system of
original transmission with girls they're
only in the context of women's circles
needs knowledge about
when the presentations our second
speaker is the joint director of the
Center for salvation sororities and
strategies the internal first generation
so your Turkish immigrants in France
Thank specialist one we're inviting me
but I think I had very hard task to
speak at a last speaker or a session
after large sorry afternoon New York
your old tyrant I'm completely jet lag
it's time to go that to me often why
more milk after all these excellent
presentation and a little different i
hope you won't sleep doing half an hour
yes i would try to keep some some
information on the Turkish Michaels
living in France even the title the term
of Turks in France is a problematic
title we know that approximately there
are 200,000 approximately Turkish
citizens living in friends and the we
estimate that there are 200,000 French
citizens but Kurdish background living
plant is difficult to calculate because
we don't have a professional
statistics they can be double the
castellan ship or single trench in
geotechnical to operate but we consider
that we have approximately 400,000
people related to Turkey one way or
another related turkey because they are
not all ethnic Turks there is a huge my
annuity with in the minority willingly
people are coming from Turkey which is
the Kurdish minority of course and all
these 400,000 people are Muslims we do
not include in this in the way of
calculating and identifying Turks and
people already from Turkey we are
nothing pudding all non-muslims
originating from Turkey but the vegan
friends are really important 100,000
French armies are coming from other non
Muslim population also see reacts
chaldean etc so we are talking about the
Muslims belonging to has been learned
not to live no salistes or practice and
belonging to Islam and even for dads
would have some problems because
approximately twenty percent twenty to
thirty percent of this Turkish minority
in France belong to Allah be religion so
to put this this group within the group
of Muslims is problematic because they
they have a different discourse liberal
clays etc you see that the existing
a difficult story history of people
originated in Kentucky in friendly very
well known after 1964 the pilot lagrima
between friends and turkey like all
other migration teeth very non vibration
coming in France as workers and adapter
1974 of the BL the agreement they could
bring their wives and children and it
became a real minority in in France half
of this population we think are born in
France this is the problem of the
generation I am listening to you since
this morning I've done much and thank
you very much for all these
communications but we are I have
impressions we are using this term of
second-generation as it was something
very nation and no we know all that
disturbing the concept of second
generation is a very very problematic
concept what we call secondary is it
enough to be born in France or to be
educated in France all maybe it must be
people born in France from parents born
in France which one both grunt or one of
these burns earlier at the track we have
many many problem with this terminal
second generation and I think that there
is a Jewish specificity in Turkish
specificity people originating from
completely but Joker purgatory
specificity since 1980s many studies on
the line this specificity I think too
much there is no one single Turkish
group which is completely different from
the other one is in implants for in
Western Europe in general but in this
case of generation case I think there is
a specificity and attraction to explain
animal acts on some characteristic
wireless specificity maybe explanation
for example it is a length language
after 1960s they repair is no migration
substantial migration from Turkey words
Western Europe before 1960s so like it
is also a group without French culture
it's very money because I mean all these
migration in friends we are separating
people from X colonies who know French
language this french- but who has a
difficult relationship between friends
for knives oh my it's a trap so there is
no this history between France and to be
this proximity of hate and love between
aronson to get even there is a
ideological history between France and
George
the Turkish revolution had pop open
spaces from the French Revolution and
franchisee of nation state and this is
maybe host or one of the rhythms of the
specific difficult the Turkish what we
love nation-state exclusivist identity
is very similar to french exclusivist
identity the same rules of constructing
the ed building the nation nation human
process are going on in Turkey and in
France that's why I need Turkish
identity and French items they are rival
right congruence between Turkish and
generally difficult to construct a
discourse of w belonging to the French
pneus and to be to the Turkish pneus and
he went for the religion I mean we were
talking with simona about this Islam
from France Islam of France is done in
French Islam friendship values this is
very very well-known
deterritorialization of the religion or
nation-state each nation stage one
territory like a nation like the
religion a little something it is like
not impressed and it is my million
turkey also so this territory rotation
of the religion Turkish time of Islam in
the French dialogue Islam the process
are very similar but there is a
comprehensive it easy to put a sock
maybe as while also erase this this
d idea of the transformation from an
empire very strong Empire to the
nation-state less strong nation state or
similar in press Enter key is proud of
being an empire and donate in the world
but to be a less strong today but in a
nation state national center for true
relationship are similar so you see that
there is this specificity of identity
building is a specially for multiple and
identity in Turkish in the Turkish case
i will discuss i will try to discuss
this concept of second generation that I
think but try to explain myself I think
that we are indicators in what I call in
some articles where I got a strategy of
Perpetual first generation I don't think
that there is a second or third
generation of thirst in in France I
started to think about that along this
strategy of purgative first generation
in 2002 in 2002 they asked me if I'm
working at Southern University I
teaching two different departments
international relations institute and
interesting people and this Turkish that
is dept we have many many courses or
Turkish language
history sociology etcetera and in 2002
the French history of the National
Education asked me to participate in the
jury's of a Columbia around in English
properly did you know the final exam I
school for Turkish Turkish language
introduced elevation so pupils students
I skootums can say the Turkish language
and history as one of their courses and
then they had a written exam and then
they burst early example of its a man we
discuss in Turkish and I have to
evaluate they were degree of Turkey in
Turkish language interpreter which
culture in stone yet the job as so I
started to do let between 2002 and 2005
two or three years i will surely hope he
declare so i had a chance to see
approximately 800 French young men and
young women 18 19 years old with Turkish
background so most of all maybe all our
boring friends and for some of them the
parents are born in France at the end of
the conversation during the oral Island
giving text reading in Turkish to us
with some personal text comprehension
little extra I started to ask the first
and main question when a Turkish guy
needs another Turkish guy with question
where are you from it we asked which I
need and it was well first question is
very from before you will be named as
is really the micro below me in Turkish
society is very very important thing and
I was told to myself that I will need
some space I will see in from which
region of friends they are coming all
those parties at the trap decision the
first and second and third and
dependence attract gay all the same
answer the village or is it a fruit
George W interesting so I was waiting be
the first one will tell the end for
Perry central I don't know one cansado I
would know and I was asking come on when
did you come to France her young horny
am ordering in French in my parents walk
around but still still the second third
generation were giving this place is
microblogging placed as there some
people some young people I said I am
living enticing don't know sorry I say
you came time for my addresses that
angle roads at Salzburg in Paris rest
but I live in pricing never read it
technically it comes in a very very
broken so what is that what is that what
is this you know this link to the
geographical origin to the parents and
even Rembrandt and then I try to develop
this I hope to struggle your first
generation I think that this strategy
exists and this strategy uses three
types of agent for transmission of
identity to pertain to keep always the
first generation there in practice that
the generations born in France educated
in France socialize in France feel feel
the same things towards turkey Turkey
parents and the Brenner it's available
Simmons it succeed for the first agent
of transmission of identity national
identity Turkish identity or even
traditionally who it is a little
different to take the traditionally
teaches language and crystallization
teachers there are two types of Turkish
education in the French system we have I
think they are 94 all friends Turkish my
wish servants of the French educational
system only 94 not zero few children few
Phillips but ninety percent maybe ninety
five percent of the education of the
Turkish language and Turkish the
causation history are made by what we
call elko this morning so I talk about
alko alko is insane you on the wrong
with you blushing
the education of culture and language
from the originated country and they are
sad by the Turkish government they are
paid by Turkish government and they give
they make some sunglasses in the French
public schools but not during the
school's wednesday is afternoon 00 or
weekends and should be French peasant
young men and young girls are gay are
following these courses in the principal
but given by a traditional Turkish
teacher so just put one side is language
courses but just to understand that in
all surveys but the Turkish language in
France everybody else of all parents
alternates and so that they want to have
teachers from Turkey authenticity to be
from Turkey to be to speak the real
Turkish it's a fact they don't have they
don't work even the dil own children
educated children become a teacher form
or the Turkish language I mean it's a
problem present bellini Department of
Turkish studies we have this you know
the source we can educate teachers
that is they do not want they want to be
related linked directly to the original
to the authority Turkish these varieties
teaches so the first agent of
transmission the language and language
yes especially language not only stir
that especially the language we know
that in the minority situation what we
call identity has two legs language and
religion we know that it is difficult to
transmit the minority language and a
majority situation and the religion
becomes in the minority reservation the
main identification able to the incident
to be a national identity national
epidemic so the second agent of
transmission of identity services our
Imams we made a study in 2002 and 2003
on the moms with the color to buy from
progressive political scientist excuse
me and we try to understand what who are
these Imams working in France always
enjoyed Turkish girls and so this study
at the publish it in 2004 on amongst in
in France as idols at that we never said
that approximately sixty percent of
Imams and Turkish moms working in the
French most Turkish French must are sad
by two Turkish government between
nineteen sixty four and 1983 so during
20 years the Turkish government were
very far from the from these migrants
settled in France and Germany in the
balance countries during these 20 years
Brotherhood associations political Islam
especially me giggles the national
vision opened some mosques in France and
in Germany the center was mr. always
karate girl in journey and but even
those people imported from Turkey some
Imams coming in Germany and friends in
the rock country dinero del in Belgium
to work in the Turkish masts after 1983
when the Turkish tournament started to
Sandy's Imams by a dt the election
zombie Religious Affairs the Union
Turkish Muslim Union it's the name of
the institution of Yogi's even after
that Association which are not in the
next work of the official Turkish state
as well they continue to use to outwork
emails coming freshly from Turk knock
condoms when we when we conducted a
study in 2002 I wasn't touch with
approximately 80 Imams in Turkish waters
no one single among women friends for
more than two years all amounts were
coming fresh from church which is very
interesting for us because after 2007
recently we started in France a real
debate as you know training Imams the
French mouths knowing the French
language the French tradition the French
Way of life the French they will get
Republican Imams and some initiative be
taken for training involved in friends
especially as you know maybe the
technical institute of paris started a
program of training options very funny
to see that people are going to the
Catholic exited to be involved and then
played during the French mosques in
stressful we starting 2008 last year a
program of master o Islam ology to train
some Muslim what intellectual nuts
amount
who will be the internal Twitter between
the French society and the Muslim
connect so to see if there was an
attempt and reception for all these
training programs we made the sugar in
2009 just plus i was injured bald goatee
turkish muscles i went to all these
Turkish matter i explained the cage we
are trying to bill the training program
for emails what do you think maybe you
will you will hire one of these emails
or your loss it's a crisis approximately
ninety percent of the answers or whether
it was known of course Imams must come
from jerk even our Imams people who are
from the Turkish community from Dale
community having a strain here in France
are not considered as a tentative
original epic a telekinetic capable to
make to be involved in the Turkish much
so still today a specificity of the
Turkish community in his at the case for
the Lord not really which are accepting
these imaging
breath his specificity of the tourist
communal community is still importing
Imams from from Turkey in that sense
it's very difficult for the Turkish
community in France to be included in
this discourse of territorial edition of
Islam the French is not because among
the main you know religious a minister
we here in front are coming yesterday
contact and for that for that reason
also it is very a huge mistake to
consider all these amounts more than
what they are doing as social agents you
know to be mediate between the society
and minority it's a critical day to not
speak French they are both themselves
who is coming to us for all these e
masta who have an interview with you
could you please give me the address
with your most 101 completely lost one
year two years three years in France
without French language in a small
community so in battling these
conditions it is very difficult to see
the Turkish community in this disc or
for constructing apprentice
non-territorial eyes next one managed by
the French system so the second agent of
transmission of identity Turkish this to
be done direct link with Turkey and
Turkish Islam and third one this is late
we were saying about the Indigo I think
that the the main thing important for
imported from Turkey to France they are
young men and young women statistically
Turks people from Turkey in France are
not very interesting the numbers so
mixed marriages are existed are absent
just put all marriages out are mixed
with in a very handsome but big cultural
clicks Mary marriages between Turks and
umbrage yes we don't let but again
statistically Turks are not very terse
in friends either Oh young men and young
women price are important from Turkey it
is an under getting yes Laura it's a
mite group and different it is not based
on the nation talking it is not based on
only on you religious tongue in our
region might look below so today
approximately i think the figure was
nice for prozac
conduct study 2004 with God from new
cabinets that we do that here all
children born in France so we can
consider them now Concepcion at second
generation to generation have at least
one of two parents coming freshly hunter
and in majority models so the
transmission of the identity of the
dilution Turkish this is through all
these mothers having freshly fresh flow
to France for the language for the
religion traditions behavior vision way
of saying the world how to speak up to
eat all the cultural are given for these
mothers curry just week ago from turn in
under these conditions to consider this
population these kids bowling friends as
a second-generation I think since they
say conceptual mistake a degradation in
addition the globalization rate that it
is very easy to make to have the
circulation of radiation physically to
go to Turkey the combative 21 hours it
is very easy to have some products from
Turkey some from who Oh produce them in
Europe one of the informations for a
berth Turkish house in television is the
aquarium
it'll always be short or something or OS
soon they are they are always under the
source of information on turkey it helps
to keep this this identity as it passed
it is still a savage man finish follow
this strategy exists to kill the
identity of the first generation but in
reality we know that this identity is
dynamic we know that the discourse of
being turn from turkey is a strong
distort and on these young people but
still in this tile and identity there is
a mix of being French and be Turkish it
is very interesting to see that before
2000 among our students Turkish
background since we started to heal the
discourse of multiple identity with our
friendship jerks at the same level etc
when the Turkish when turkey became the
official candidate to the European Union
the discourse in Fred had been
radicalized against Turkey not because
turkey wasn't in Europe but Turks were
Europeans and by reaction after 2000 we
started the new an exclusivist identity
discos front doors of your only choice
we are not friends but in reality of
course they say is in French I mean you
see we can say that this base of the day
construction the building of the new
identity and for new minority in
is an ongoing process an existing
process strategy exists but i think and
hope please calm down to read thank you
very much for you we have a lot of
computer core materials of theoretical
insights on the table for discussion and
I'd like to invite anyone in the
audience would like to make a comment or
ask a question or another miracle data
to the cloud becomes when you do speak
if you can please introduce yourself and
say where you're from it
Muhammad never American University I
want to raise an ethical question the
same question I raised on Muslim
Brotherhood in America I'm going to
raise it regarding the behavior of the
of the French nationals and I'm going to
use the same approach looking at
Nationals of citizens with foreign
attachment applying this idea to France
so from what I learned from the
presentations of all de France allows
and ported Imams made by foreign
governments tolerates the interference
of foreign governments in elections in
my ority communities in France and they
allow turkish foreign teachers to come
and teach another French culture to the
public students in France and then
questioned the freshness of of their own
senses I think if this is something
wrong you brought it on yourselves and
you have to just acknowledge that you
are dealing with with with a situation
where you have French citizens in a in a
global age friends is actually benefited
by making those minority communities
self-reliant because if I if they cannot
support themselves for those basic needs
the French government will have to pay
for
and yet they allow up for governments to
pay for them and then you go after your
own citizens and tell them on French
argue I think there is an ethical
question to be asked stemming from the
situation I appreciate just 27 you are
right but I will be very cynical on
since the creation of CFC from M the
French Council of Muslim college from
French government all French cold all
these important Imams pay by these
foreign countries were very good cause
one customer paid by the brain kolkata
danapur background but secondary control
by different countries all these foreign
cars were culturally he is called of
these evolves and when there is a
problem with all these in with the
Disco's they can have positive agreement
between friends and this this country's
culture Leah and enter key after the
creation of CSS is here I yell trance
became pretty building of french french
kissin and maybe not today friends is
capable to control this all his phone
amount H what we see today all these
training training programs for polygon
spots without inside name was between
France enter the third countries for
friends it was seen as a tangent clearly
as a danger so to have some free amounts
they prepare to have amongst control by
Rocco Jerry abide by Turkey and pay by
my turkey so it is not humanistic for
multicultural approaches which are
allowing the
this month is really cynical and
secretary Franco varies but after the
creation of and because of that they
control Islam and they say to his amount
to practical cost the CFC and William
world about step Ciara real elected
consul of Turkey editor the Muslim cold
in France on suitcases the first was the
heads currency it became a what the
voice of the government to explain we
feel what was why it was for Minister
the second when sue French owners have
been kidnapped in Iraq they went to
Europe to explain that French wasn't the
country against them that they are to
live is these two journals that's all
that's all it is a real artificial after
issue in tradition instructed by friends
in this narration to control to
territory over there is a spirit Turkish
way of thinking on that point of view
turkeys in theory the Religious Affairs
directory administration
well I'm wondering if the Turkish Kurds
identified in well I am sorry Turkish
pneus Turkish kiss has three different
definitions the first definition of
Turkish this is a legal one article 66
of the Turkish competition is saying
that people who are linked to the
Turkish Republic by the way of TV series
of art rock stars on that one whole
point of view turks legally archers and
because there is no truth is not
recognized what they are counted as two
at urban cities but they can have of
course the ethnic I am the second
identification of the Turkish news is
good news Muslim Turkish speaker but
Muslim not only Muslim but multiple
Muslim to meet on a TV etc even for
other these there are some some problem
and the third hit third definition is a
ratio on all the terms from Central Asia
till the ball comes from Turkish nation
certified sure are more and more in
identifying themselves as terms and
claiming hidden day core business to
reason to that first of all current
speed in Turkish migration after 1960s
to the Western Europe and there they
found a more liberal environment to
express their identity it was quite
impossible in Turkey was quite
impossible to work until the end of
nineteen name
it was impossible new people new world
of pure muscle injury and secondly today
the traditional became one of the main
problem debate in Turkey and is free to
express its and even if there are many
many problems so 13 Western Europe are
sometimes with courage but awfully they
consider a real identical and ethical
ethical group just there is a problem
some curves because of the simulations
policies in jerky are not foolish
speakers so they had there is a
linguistic problem but other girls are
produced occurs and so they both need a
special and more is not the majority but
most of them are LEDs there are some
other ways in Polish
I'm using trans just about very much for
your attention we're just commands for
the Turkish in collisions on skyline be
Slade and I will I met some parents and
thanks to you I was able to fuse my
parents thanks to children because
indeed after a third third third rows in
front scallops where roads able to speak
in French I was impressed by the ability
of Paris to transmit a broadness of
aubergine so I think it's also important
to televise this because many families
for example North African families there
is no progress of foraging and we
understand it very well because
colonization war between France and
Algeria
Angelina it's not necessarily a source
of progress very lousy some Turkish
companies I was impressed by the fact
that some father allowed to talk about
Mustafa Kemal then I'd to talk about the
past of Turkey and that's why
reichsfhrer poverty one family first
please tweet with you not because it was
Christopher winning dragon pictures he
was so pleased to speak about Turkey a
big poster of Mustafa Kemal in living
room and cause permanent link with
turkey from the television because it's
not Tara and France very it's Turkish
television I think aside your progress
is is important it perhaps perhaps it's
something positive by the way it's not
normative front of you that I have but
Romero so admire this ability to
transmit protest of origin my question
for you is about don't you think that
the stronger belonging with regard
reverse psychology if inter distribution
is also questioned a challenge of France
what extent does is to what extent is
from able to find you ethnic minority
groups and their belongings in strums is
involved in this world
it is a huge general I do not think that
it's a positive thing is approximately
eight years of great Washington made
that the Turkish education again to the
old in Turkish generation the Turks must
be proud to return center which
nationalisms a try but it created
exclusives identity also it's very
difficult to conceal himself at the same
time turf and something else as it is
very difficult to convey the French and
some take something as I think that the
multiple identity is very difficult in
the bridge trainer the French contacts
quarter specifically it's a double
challenge for turkey turkish an antenna
and the French and until well it's a
real challenge to change in title for
guidance the influence but also in
Turkey to be able to build this this
multiple identity Charlotte the who the
famous Armenian singer friends were
saying i feel myself hundred percent
French and pollen percent are made from
French people and for a new Turkish
people to keep himself a lot dozen
something at one opponent there is no
presentation of the I guess so I think
it is a challenge but I don't think this
it's so my name is Carl Meyer
Connecticut and I'm fascinated Jared
Strasburg and I'm wondering to what
extent intuitively or by direct evidence
with your description of the Turkish
community in France also applies to
Germany Italy the Scandinavian countries
Denmark Belgium is it he replied
phenomena well it is a specificity of
the French context I have to confess in
Germany it's a little bit little bit
because the
also second generation but still around
well more than half yeah mazal do
without you know but there are still it
is the same picture and also the
relationship between identifying with
turkey and identifying such as well as
relation to edit
so people who feel more Dutch feel less
their patient feel that they are being
Muslims more important to them that they
are strong representatives also feel
less touch or Turkish or Moroccan so
yeah we do see that it's sort of in some
way I'm going to wrap him up we went up
after four o'clock restore so many
things that people wanted to talk about
the screen we're going to reconvene at
four-thirty for the final afternoon so
it's coffee was right